arrancamos con nuestra Crónica de
cultura sobre los primeros días de la
filbo la Feria Internacional del Libro
de Bogotá uno de los mayores eventos
literarios del continente y para eso hoy
nos acompaña desde la filbo nuestra
periodista League lea Buenas noches la
feria del libro empezó el martes y dura
hasta el 2 de mayo en la capital
colombiana y sus primeros momentos
fueron marcados por las palabras de su
invitada central
exactamente María Clara hace solo cuatro
días que las puertas de la filbo están
abiertas y uno de los eventos más
esperados de esta edición 35 fue el
conversatorio con la escritora nigeriana
algunos la conocen por sus muy
aplaudidas novelas como americana y
medio sol Amarillo o sus ensayos
feministas pero para quién está
descubren con esta Crónica
de Cartel este año eso se sintió en los
pasillos de corferías durante la rueda
de prensa que ya dio el miércoles sus
fans se paraban afuera de la sala donde
estábamos con todos nosotros periodistas
para gritar su nombre y el mismo fervor
se vio durante su charla en auditorio
lleno hasta sus escaleras donde los
lectores de la nigeriana se sentaron
para escucharla hablar de racismo de
duelo de Raíces y de educación de hecho
en cada una de sus intervenciones en la
montaña
por su pedagogía y a la pregunta Qué
hacer para llegar a una mejor
representación de las personas de color
en los países latinoamericanos la
escritora explicó el papel de la cultura
y habló de la importancia del arte
audiovisual para cambiar las Mentes la
escuchamos
Qué hay en la televisión que ve la gente
no sé pero en las telenovelas en los
dramas populares hay personajes negros
y si los hay son normales y corrientes o
siempre tienen algún problema porque eso
también importa porque ahí es donde
creas estereotipos si no representas a
las personas como simples seres humanos
me refiero a lo que ha ocurrido a veces
en Estados Unidos donde durante un
tiempo veías series en las que los
personajes negros siempre Tenían un
problema no se les permitía hacer
Simplemente ya sabes Buscar el amor
reírse e ir de copas siempre había un
problema y creo que lo que hace es que
ves eso a menudo entonces empiezas a
pensar que eso es lo único que hace la
gente negra tener problemas así que creo
que puede cambiar pero con esfuerzo
no ha sido el único gran rostro de esta
edición de la filbo que se presentó ante
el público Durante los primeros días
cierto
Así es María Clara creo que sería muy
Injusto de hablar de las grandes figuras
de la filbo este año sin hablar de la
canadiense
y recautivó a Los visitantes de la feria
por su perfil bien particular
y a los 10 años huyó con su familia de
la guerra para llegar como refugiada en
Canadá pero no en cualquier parte de
Canadá Quebec en la región francofona y
su escena literaria tan colorida por el
francés que se habla allá como ella
misma me estaba contando y su amor por
este idioma y toda la cultura que
conlleva yo creo que ella lo transmitió
con éxito a Los visitantes
latinoamericanos
soy muy privilegiada de poder hablar del
que ve que es aquí pero la lengua que
bequense no es sólo una lengua para mí
la lengua que bequense es la que me ha
dado una segunda vida un segundo
nacimiento Así que la lengua que vequeza
es para mí una lengua del amor nunca
podría escribir en otra lengua que no
fuera el que es imposible mientras que
hoy quizá podría escribir directamente
en inglés pero no porque cuando
escribimos compartimos la belleza de las
cosas la belleza de los seres humanos la
belleza de las situaciones Así que
debemos utilizar la lengua del amor que
es el que ve que
es loco
lea y la filmo no es solo un evento con
escritores qué más se puede ver María
Clara la feria del libro de Bogotá
también Abre espacios artistas que no
solo escriben o que a veces no escriben
en absoluto y sobre todo se nota que la
filbo intenta ofrecer más y más espacio
de conversaciones entre artistas
indígenas como el conversatorio entre
las fotógrafas
México el país invitado de honor este
año Juliette Morales es una artista del
pueblo misaki que vive en el
departamento del cauca en el sur de
Colombia y ella utiliza la fotografía
para explorar y hacer una introspección
de su cuerpo y así entender mejor su
experiencia de mujer indígena mientras
que marus cuenta su territorio y
registra material y plantas de su pueblo
sutil en el estado de Chiapas en México
en esta charla estas artistas
compartieron como desde el arte quieren
guardar una memoria ancestral y logran
exponer el resto del resto del mundo del
Poder y la belleza de sus realidades